the animals of history have been used to
inspire and inform great video games
since well pretty much always from games
like the Oregon Trail to dynasty
Warriors Total War to battlefield
Assassin's Creed to Kingdom Come
deliverance while some games are more
accurate than most there are games out
there that where their accuracy as a
badge of honor game design often
involves compromise which can be tricky
when it comes to historical accuracy how
much change is too much how far should
have developer go to be historically
accurate and should sacrifices be made
if rigidly following history proves
itself to be exclusionary if we are to
take historical accuracy to mean the
accurate representation of historical
fact and the commonly accepted view of
events and games already have a huge
challenge in being a representation of
history free agency and interactivity
mean that things will inevitably stray
from the real-world timeline while many
elements of Assassin's Creed origins are
pretty bang on especially when it comes
to aspects like architecture and the
political strife at the time you're
playing a fictional character whose
actions are in his own they're yours
total war puts a lot of effort into
creating an authentic campaign with
units and maps accurate to the
represented era but as a commander and a
ruler you shape the world of your
conquests and politics the more you play
the further away from the real-life
timeline you go but that's not a
critique that's just the nature of the
medium but these examples show that
games can be flexible that there is room
for change and different interpretations
while still being historically accurate
in many ways developers still have free
agency to make additions or subtractions
and players will always be able to put
their own spin on things as they play
when I got to try out totall or saga
Thrones Britannia I spoke to jackal us
did the game director and asked about
the challenges on creating games that
are constrained by staying loyal to the
history books he said historical
accuracy is more what we tend to term as
historical authenticity it's trying to
get the feel of the time period across
making sure that the unit's look like
they were historically accurate the
names and places feel accurate that when
you go through the game you're not going
to go hang on this is wrong for the era
it's all about trying to get that
feeling across like if you go for full
accuracy you're going to have things
like on the campaign half your troops
die before you get to battle because of
disease or a battle where you can't
control anything in you're sort of
watching as things play out over several
hours it's where you draw the line on
the accuracy
a hundred percent accuracy is pretty
much impossible for these games a lot of
these periods if you did it completely
accurate as well it will be completely
alien to one sector of people because
the different social and societal
expectations Jack's use of the term
historical authenticity is an
interesting point it's here where
developers find the flexibility to
present an interpretation of history
while retaining a sense of accuracy
assassin's creed origin still feels
authentic despite the fact that I fought
a giant alligator God total war still
feels authentic despite allowing me to
amass an army of dogs and conquer Europe
and well I couldn't be looking at
historical accuracy in video games right
now without talking about the issue that
came up when Kingdom Come deliverance
was released for those of you who might
be out of the loop Kingdom Come
deliverance launch without any people of
color present in the game this
understandably led to discussions about
the presence of people of color in the
game's time period its developers
reaction to this criticism on the lack
of representation and how coverage of
the title from the media should be
approached for his part the initial
response from warhorse Studios writer
Daniel Vavra was to take to Twitter and
state that there were no black people in
medieval premia this he said was based
on consulting with top historians he
went on to question if people really
think warhorse Studios would be making
historically accurate game from its own
country without knowing its own history
the Sun walked combative response drew
some criticism and VEVRAA later made a
statement to gamestar de where he said I
apologize for my lack of care and
thoughtlessness in my personal
communication which has led to
misunderstandings in the past should I
hurt feelings or give the impression of
propagating a kind of ideology I
apologize for that Barbara went on to
talk about the issues that were in
dispute specifically on the matter of
the ethnic composition of the population
of Bohemia in the Middle Ages when and
where Kingdom Come takes place probably
the most serious allegation of the
current debate revolves around the
accusation that we would actively deny
the presence of people of other skin
color or ethnicity in our game and thus
promote a racist worldview that's wrong
I personally do not deny this fact
nor does Kingdom Come deliverance limit
itself to any ethnic group the
nationality of other characters reflects
what we know about Bohemia in 1403 as
already mentions the plot of Kingdom
Come deliverance is limited to a limited
area of today's Czech Republic an area
that lies far inland from the European
continent based on our sources the
region was mainly populated by pea
whose regional origin is in present-day
Czech Republic Germany Poland or Belgium
in addition the sources speak of a few
people of Italian origin who worked
mainly as stonemasons and architects in
the big cities and a Jewish community of
course the situation the time looked
more heterogeneous in some other
countries countries whose coasts have
been heavily traveled for example
through maritime trade we have already
dealt extensively with historians and
historical sources while preparing for
the work of the game when the first
allegations were made I reiterated and
intensified this discourse to make sure
that we do not portray history in any
altered form credit where credit is due
it sounds like the designers of warhorse
did their due diligence and they even
went on to cite their sources and
literature they used however a number of
historians disagree with their findings
and design decisions German magazine M
games asked the historical Institute of
Aachen University and Johannes Gutenberg
University mains who said there were at
most Turkish people like the humans who
appear as the enemies in game but
otherwise said the presence of non-white
people could be questionable there is
however some evidence including art
pieces that include people of color in
medieval Bohemia like st. jerome from
the Theodoric of Prague from 1360 or
John of a paver from the st. Matthew
evangelist Terry from 1368 of course I'm
not a historian so I tried to do some
research into the debate myself I got in
touch with Professor David to avril from
the University College of London and he
said I wouldn't go so far as to say that
the existence of any people of color in
late medieval Bohemia was impossible but
we would be talking about a
statistically my new proportion of the
population nevertheless games that
follow history to the letter based on
what ancient tomes and history book said
aren't infallible history at the end of
the day is both found and written by
humans humans can make mistakes or miss
things out they can have both conscious
and unconscious bias or a dear to long
term cultural constructs that sway
arguments or subconsciously lead those
who read it and of course history is
written from the author's own point of
view and they can often exclude many
other considerations at the time using
history to create any form of media
involves picking through these ancient
biases and cultural concerns and even
rewrites to what may have been taking
place over centuries but developers have
already shown that they're willing to be
flexible when using history for the
basis for games Call of Duty World War 2
for example authentically uses the
Second World War to present its story
and as a setting for its multiplayer but
they made the decision to allow
to play as female American infantry
despite female soldiers never serving on
the front lines
total war presented a unified Russia in
a time where they were actually
bickering fiefdom
in order to allow for smoother gameplay
instances such as these of which there
are many show that it is possible to be
authentic to a time period in place
while also taking some liberties to be
inclusive without compromising the
realism although traditionally thought
of as an entertainment medium at games
can be a powerful tool to teach total
war taught me about kingdoms and
technologies I never knew about and
sparked an interest in Roman culture
when I was young
games like Medal of Honor Call of Duty
and il-2 Sturmovik made me interested in
learning more about World War two and I
only knew who's Joan of Arc and William
Wallace were because of Age of Empires 2
and now more recently Assassin's Creed
origins discovery tour has an entire
separate mode designed to teach me about
ancient Egypt Assassin's Creed origins
especially is being praised for its
attention to detail and discovery tour
for leveraging this as an educational
tool but even then discovery tour still
makes small concessions for censorship
most notably it covers up nude statues
which otherwise would prevent younger
audiences from being able to utilize it
again this is another example of making
changes without undermining authenticity
in a major way changes that provide an
environment that's more accessible and
inclusive to everyone here both girls
and boys are shown attending a class
given by one of the rhetorician 's of
the era the team made the choice to show
both genders attending class within the
context of the game world even though it
is historically inaccurate the team felt
it was not necessary to prioritize
historical sexism over inclusive
gameplay it's difficult for developers
and designers to be able to pass every
source of information especially if they
believe themselves to be working off
accurate historical documents but at the
same time we have this idea of
authenticity and games over bang-on
accuracy but if you're basing your
creation on what someone else has
written in a history book further
scrutiny is warranted especially where
those ancient hang-ups are magnified
into the modern mostly more intelligent
public eye
why should we follow it so strictly or
restrict creativity and inclusivity and
the enjoyment of a product so my
question to you would be do you think
it's possible to create historically
accurate or historically
and to games that are loyal and respect
the source material of history while
also respecting the full spectrum of
people that could be playing them do you
think games would suffer if writers and
developers allow themselves a little
more artistic license or open
interpretation when it came to use
history as their basis this isn't a
question that's easily answered and it
may be a challenge that faces games and
developers for a long time to come but
as I play a lot of historical games and
as I saw the discussion surrounding
Kingdom Come deliverance and seeing both
sides of the conversation surrounding
that game it's a thought that I found
interesting and a question I wants to
pose to you guys I hope it sparked some
civil conversation in the comments
section below I'll be in there checking
out your thoughts thank you so much for
watching I hope you found this little
video interesting or at least a little
thought-provoking and I look forward to
seeing you in the next one
you